my talk at the table is award-winning
writer and magazine editor tina brown
who spent three decades chronicling the
british monarchy her latest book we got
it right here it's called the palace
papers inside the house of windsor the
truth and the turmoil is an in-depth
look at the past 25 years of britain's
royal family going back to the final
days of princess diana brown spoke to
more than 120 people who've been closely
involved with the senior royals and
their household their information allows
her to tell a fascinating and revealing
story about the monarchy in the modern
area in a modern era with a particular
focus on its female members tina brown
is also a cbs news royal contributor and
is here with us good morning to you
vladimir it is so good to see you so
good to be here i love all of your books
about the royal family i love when you
come on and you talk about the royal
family these people love the royals in
this video they really really love
fascinating this one is a humdinger i
mean it's excellent and you've written
extensively about the relationship
between prince william and prince harry
and that has a lot of people buzzing
talking tongues wagging what have you
learned about their relationship it's
really
been
sort of unraveling since
really a couple of years before megan
came on the scene
so that's what's interesting yeah she
has she has been i think unfairly over
blamed for it actually because it was
starting to go
sideways when harry came out of the army
after 10 years and suddenly you know he
was there he was like this charismatic
number two he wanted big assignments he
wanted to be out there on the public
stage and realized you know sort of for
the first time seriously that his
brother his partner diverged he's now
the future king they're no longer
diana's boys they're no longer the two
boys who were peers and best friends and
best buddies inevitably william was
on the path for kingship harry was the
number two instead of harry didn't kind
of get that memo he didn't
like it he didn't like being
marginalized and they started to have a
lot of disagreements about the fact that
harry was getting the better less less
good assignments than william that
william always had obviously first dibs
you know on where he was going to travel
i never got this since harry wanted to
be king either so it's not he doesn't
want to be yeah he didn't want to be
king but he wanted to feel that his uh
gifts which were considerable you know
were being deployed in a more meaningful
way than he felt that they were you have
a chapter that i think is very aptly
named duke of hazard and you're talking
about andrew i just your comedic touch
tina's throughout the book it's very
smart it's pretty very cleverly written
yeah
duke of hazard because he
everyone says that he's his mom's
favorite
and then he caused quite a lot of
trouble for his mother
well unfortunately i mean andrew for a
long time has been a coronated sleaze
machine i mean he really has wow
that's a quote yes terrible taste in in
people you know he consorted with the
worst people he was always money
grubbing
feeling he didn't have enough money
because again you know as the second son
he had you know just the allowance and
he wasn't allowed to make any really in
and that's what they live on the
allowances yeah that's right and so he
was always sort of scrabbling and he
always ended up with the worst company
and of course ended up you know becoming
a friend of jeffrey epstein which was
really his downfall
you know the book focuses a lot on the
women in the royal family specifically
megan a lot uh especially at the
beginning and it's really fascinating to
me you said she didn't feel that
she didn't really know what she was
getting into and you found that hard to
believe
well it was interesting to me that um
you know she memorably told tel loper i
didn't do any research and
my question was you know in her
working life all the people i spoke to
in her acting life and her you know when
she was a you know a tv star they all
said she was so good at preparation you
know that she was somebody who was asked
for director's notes who boned up the
night before who was highly organized
about her material
it's very odd to me that you know for
the biggest role of her life namely
becoming a member of the royal family
and a royal duchess that she says she
did no research i think had she done so
she might have
you know had a few question marks about
what this life was going to be i really
don't think she understood what it was
like to be
married to in fact the sixth in line to
the throne yeah i i think that that
interview that she did a long time ago
where she said i knew it would be hard i
didn't but i thought it would be fair
but that's a whole nother part of the
story but let's talk about the queen
because you said most royal life is
crushingly dull now the queen is about
to
celebrate 70 years on the throne and
prince charles will soon be king charles
that's that's going to happen right
because there are so many some people
think well maybe it'll go to prince
william no he's not going to let this
slide on no i would wait
you know in the auntie room of his
destiny for 50 years he's not gonna say
okay you know william you take it and in
this country we think you know she's 90
plus she just celebrated we think why
wouldn't she just step down and give it
to her son and you said that's just not
the way it works it's not going to
happen um she believes that she's there
quote all the days of my life which was
her vow and her coronation plus she
loves her job and she still likes it she
likes to be involved and
right now of course she keeps cancelling
engagements which is very hard and and
very upsetting to people because you
know everybody's looking with
trepidation how long can she last her
mother lasted a hundred plus yes she did
she did and she liked being the center
of the action
very good very good genes tina
congratulations thank you gail the name
of tina's book is the palace papers do
you mind if i hold it up to camera my
mind
it goes on sale tomorrow wherever you
like to buy your books